whether you believe it's a cake or a
tart it's safe to say that cheesecake is
one of our favorite desserts here at
tasty we tested a bunch of different
recipes and techniques to find a
foolproof ultra creamy vanilla
cheesecake
so here's how to make a classic
crack-free cheesecake
[Music]
every good cheesecake starts with a
springform pan greasing the pan with
non-stick spray or butter is going to
help easy removal and help prevent
cracking down the line adding a band of
parchment paper will ensure you've got
those smooth picture perfect sides when
you go to remove the spring form
the foundation of cheesecake is the
crust it only requires three ingredients
to make a classic graham cracker crust
this is the simplest part of the recipe
the combination of sugar and butter
helps hold everything together for a
really fantastic crust
some people like using other types of
cookies you can easily swap it in right
here
we're going to do a bottom crust only
some people like the crust on the sides
it's totally a matter of preference just
use a flat surface to spread the graham
cracker mixture into an even layer
[Music]
now you're going to bake it for 8 to 10
minutes until it's golden brown and just
let it cool as you prepare the filling
now it looks like a lot of dairy but
remember it's a rich velvety dessert you
really need it here
we're adding full fat cream cheese here
this is not the time to skimp with
reduced fat i know it looks like a lot
of sugar it is we tried to reduce it but
you really miss out on some of that
classic cheesecake flavor
make sure all your ingredients are at
room temperature before getting started
this way they'll be easier to mix and
give you a smooth cheesecake without any
lumps we're adding a bit of heavy cream
it's a subtle difference but it's going
to help smooth out the batter it's a
personal preference and you can omit it
but we wouldn't
i'm adding in sour cream for a bit of
added tang and i'm also going to add
some flour which is going to help bind
the cheesecake together and help prevent
cracks to flavor the cake i'm using
whole vanilla bean a really easy way to
remove the seeds is by splitting it down
the middle lengthwise and use the blade
of your knife to slowly scrape the seeds
out
while you can use vanilla extract in a
pinch the intense flavor of a bean is
really hard to beat
eggs are crucial in any baked cheesecake
they add in creaminess and also help
bind the cheesecake together as it bakes
some recipes will call for adding extra
egg yolks we found in testing that this
makes a denser cheesecake so for our
airy version we're sticking with whole
eggs only
so add in the eggs one at a time if you
dump them in all at once you run the
risk of having a really lumpy batter
okay so this part is crucial
as soon as the eggs are incorporated
stop mixing over mixing can result in a
really dense cheesecake
you also want to be scraping your bowl
down to ensure everything is thoroughly
mixed
from here it's really easy just pour the
batter onto the cooled crust and smooth
out the top
if we didn't bake the crust it would mix
in with the batter who wants that
[Music]
even cooking and cracking is a huge
concern when making cheesecake one of
the best ways to prevent that is to use
a water bath while baking
even though the pan is sealed there
could be a slight opening where water
could get through and give you a soggy
crust
to prevent any water from seeping in
we're gonna wrap our spring form in two
sheets of foil to really seal it
place the pan in a large heavy baking
dish and fill it with hot water about
one inch up the sides of the pan
the hot water creates a moist
environment in an otherwise dry oven so
the cheesecake doesn't split from drying
out
there are several methods where you can
start your cheesecake in a hot oven and
then lower the temperature while you do
get some lift you also run the risk of
burning or cracking your cheesecake for
our recipe we're going to do a steady
moderate heat all the way through then
turn the heat off and leave the
cheesecake in the oven for another hour
to finish baking allowing the cake to
sit in the oven allows it for it to be
fully set in the middle and get a little
bit of color you can see that the cake
that was taken out after an hour isn't
fully cooked and looks like a gloopy
mess
sometimes cracks happen there are so
many reasons that can cause a crack such
as high temperature over mixing a water
bath but this doesn't mean that you
can't end up with a beautiful delicious
cheesecake in the end a great way to
cover up a cracked cheesecake is to make
a sour cream topping this topping is
really simple it's just sour cream sugar
and vanilla extract all mixed together
[Music]
it not only covers up the crack but it's
also really delicious and can be used on
uncracked cheesecakes as well
for a sour cream topping you don't need
a water bath
just bake it for 10 to 15 minutes just
so the top is set and continue the
recipe as normal
after sitting in the oven for another
hour the cheesecake needs to cool at
room temperature another way to prevent
cracks is to gently go around the rim of
the cheesecake with a knife at this
point the center of the cheesecake
should still have a slight jiggle just
like this once the cheesecake is cooled
place it in the fridge covered with
plastic wrap to fully set ideally
overnight but you can still get a really
good result in about four hours to
remove the cheesecake from the pan
unlatch the side of the spring form and
carefully lift off the frame
gently peel back the parchment and
you're going to see those beautiful
smooth sides
there's such a wide variety of toppings
you can add to your cheesecake but for
hours we're going to keep it simple with
a ton of fresh berries
to get the perfect slice fill a large
vessel with hot water dip your knife
into the water then gently pat it dry
before slicing
the hot knife will ensure that you get a
smooth cut every time
[Music]
we love serving our cheesecake with a
berry [ __ ] which is basically a fancy
word for a berry puree that has been
cooked down until it's thick it's the
perfect complement alongside all those
gorgeous fresh berries
there's a reason we make so many
cheesecakes here at tasty they're
relatively easy they're great for a
crowd and most importantly they're
downright delicious by using these tips
and tricks you too can make the
dreamiest creamiest cheesecake of your
life
[Music]